[Musik]
Deutschlands Krankenhäuser sind zu
Patienten geworden sie leiden unter
effizienzhochdruck
akutem Personalmangel und sind
krisenanfällig
[Musik]
das Geld für Krankenhäuser kommt aus
mehreren Portemonnaies Geldbeutel Nummer
eins die Bundesländer sie sind für
Investitionsmittel zuständig das heißt
sie entscheiden beispielsweise wo ein
Krankenhaus gebaut oder geschlossen wird
stellen aber auch Geld für Anschaffung
von medizinischen Geräten zur Verfügung
nicht genug sagen ExpertInnen laut der
Deutschen Krankenhausgesellschaft glaubt
hier jedes Jahr eine milliardenlücke
zwischen Bedarf und Finanzierung
Geldbeutel Nummer 2 die Träger
Krankenhäuser erhalten außerdem von
ihren Trägern Eigenmittel Überschüsse
sind nur für private Einrichtungen
interessant und bis zu 15% möglich
Geldbeutel Nummer 3 die Krankenkassen
sie finanzieren die sogenannten
Betriebskosten das ist der größte Anteil
bis zu 90% des klinikbudgets und vor
allem hier liegt das Problem für jeden
Patienten werden nach der Versorgung
nämlich zwei Abrechnungen gemacht
erstens die Fallpauschale für jede
Operation Behandlung oder ein Eingriff
sind feste Sätze vorgegeben
berechnet werden sie aus mittlerweile
mehr als 1.200 Codes für Behandlungen
diese werden jährlich angepasst und ihre
Anzahl hat sich Seite Einführung
verdoppelt
diese pauschalen orientieren sich an
Durchschnittskosten die bei einem
bestimmten Eingriff anfallen die Aufwand
Material und Personalkosten oder
Liegezeit bleibt eine Klinik darunter
bleibt ein Überschuss mit darüber liegt
hat ein Defizit
das hat zur Folge dass beispielsweise
eine gut planbare Hüft-OP deutlich mehr
Gewinn für Krankenhäuser abwirft als
eine Geburt die
Durchschnittsberechnungen beruhen auf
Daten des vorletzten Jahres tatsächlich
die Kosten weichen im Einzelfall stark
von den pauschalen ab
die zweite Abrechnung der Pflege Erlös
nach viel Kritik am alten System werden
seit 2020 die Kosten für das
Pflegepersonal separat vergütet hier
gibt es für jeden Tag die ein Patient
stationär also im Krankenhaus bleibt
eine Pauschale für die Pflege am Bett so
soll der Effizienzdruck in den
Krankenhäusern abgemildert werden
hier wählt die Regierung auch mit
Finanzspritzen gegensteuern Abteilungen
die Geburtshilfe Kinder und
Jugendmedizin sollen zusätzlich Geld
bekommen und Defizite ausgeglichen
werden
ein zusätzlicher Ansatz Kliniken müssen
in Zukunft so viele Pflegekräfte
beschäftigen wie tatsächlich benötigt
werden sonst drohen Sanktionen doch so
einfach ist das nicht umzusetzen
[Musik]
ein Job im Krankenhaus nein Danke sagen
viele Gründe für den Fachkräftemangel
erstens Krankenhaus bedeutet oft
Schichtarbeit zweitens krankenhausarbeit
ist körperlich und auch psychisch
belastend dazu kommt drittens das Gefühl
von mangelnder Wertschätzung dafür steht
für viele Mitarbeiter in auch die
schlechte Bezahlung die Zahlen nicht
besetzt das Stellen in Krankenhäusern
wird mit mindestens 27.000 beziffert
erste Ideen gegen den Fachkräftemangel
ein Teil der Behandlungen soll in
Zukunft ambulant durchgeführt werden
dadurch sollen es bis zu 25% weniger auf
den Stationen werden
Folge nachts würden weniger Personal
benötigt und das könnt ihr insgesamt
weniger Schichtdienste für die
Mitarbeiter in bedeuten
Krankenhäuser sollen außerdem
zusätzliches Geld bekommen um nicht mehr
so eng mit dem Personalplan zu müssen
wenn die Arbeitsbelastung auf mehr
Schultern verteilt werden kann bringt
dies Erleichterung für alle und es gibt
noch einen weitreichenderen
Therapieansatz die Anzahl der
Krankenhäuser soll langfristig drastisch
reduziert werden
derzeit gibt es in Deutschland knapp
1.900 Krankenhäuser viele davon relativ
klein und nicht gut ausgestattet solche
Krankenhäuser könnten geschlossen werden
in größeren und besser ausgestatteten
Kliniken sollen Kompetenzen gebündelt
werden so soll zum einen den
Fachkräftemangel entgegenwirkt und zum
anderen sollen die Spezialisierungen von
Kliniken die Patientinnen besser
versorgt werden
ein gutes Beispiel dafür die
onkologischen Zentren in Deutschland
krebskranke Menschen sollen
einheitlicher und nach hohen Standards
versorgt werden dafür wird Wissen und
Erfahrung in den Zentren gebündelt und
dann weitergegeben
[Musik]
spätestens seit der corona-pandemie ist
klar unser krankenhaussystem steckt in
einer Dauerkrise sowohl die materielle
als auch die personelle Ausstattung war
bzw ist grenzwertig und auch die
momentane Energiekrise trifft die
Kliniken heftig denn Krankenhäuser sind
energieintensiv rein rechnerisch hat ein
Krankenhausbett den Energiebedarf von
vier Einfamilienhäusern pro Jahr
bestimmte Bereiche müssen stark gekühlt
und stets frisch belüftet werden Licht
brennt und Überwachungsgeräte laufen
teilweise rund um die Uhr und die
Patientinnen dürfen es wieder zu warm
noch zu kalt haben
etwa 70% der Kliniken könnten auch durch
die hohen Energiekosten ins Minus
rutschen schätzen ExpertInnen
außerdem brauchen die Kliniken klingend
einen digitalisierungsschub der den
bürokratischen Aufwand für das Personal
verringern könnte mit einer
Finanzspritze ist es also nicht getan
Krankenhäuser brauchen ein Budget
jenseits der Fallpauschalen um
ausreichend Material und Personal
vorzuhalten so wie es beispielsweise
auch bei Feuerwehr und Polizei ist Dr
Lauterbach und die Bundesländer haben
wohl noch einige Eingriffe vor sich
bevor das krankenhaussystem genießen
kann
[Musik]